bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport on commence ce magazine par des
images de l'enterrement de l'ancien
gardien de l'équipe de france philippe
meda au nouveau cimetière de montigny le
bretonneux ce vendredi 6 octobre une
centaine de personnes est venue rendre
hommage à cet ancien barjot philippe
médard avait 58 ans est décédé des
suites d'une longue maladie
on poursuit ce magazine par le sommaire
de l'émission course la troisième
édition du run and bike de plaisir était
organisée ce samedi dans le parc du
château plus de 600 personnes ont
participé à l'événement
les détails dans ce magazine haut du be1
nouvelle défaite pour le club de
montigny le bretonneux dans le
championnat de promotion honneur les
inhumant teint se sont inclinés contre
garches 11 à 8 à la maison le résumé est
à suivre
golf les amateurs de la petite balle
blanche ont pu se tester gratuitement au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce samedi
pendant le golf expérience et sportifs
ont également pu visiter un village
ambulant sur la ryder cup nous y
reviendrons dans quelques instants
on commence tout de suite ce magazine
par l'actualité sportive de la semaine
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres coup
de projecteur sur les jeux olympiques de
2024 vous le savez paris accueillera la
plus grande compétition sportive
planétaire c'est dans ce cadre que la
ministre des sports laura flessel était
ce matin versailles la femme politique a
visité en compagnie de la directrice du
château catherine pégard et de plusieurs
élus le site qui accueillera les
épreuves d'équitation de pentathlon
moderne pendant les jo
laura flessel était au micro de nicolas
qui rit le mythe ce lieu qui va recevoir
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est un lieu qui qui a une histoire qui
est excellente donc du coup aujourd'hui
on veut continuer à travailler je dirais
dans une co-construction on va être
présent à l'écouté de toute
transformation et
et lors de la de la commission du
passage de la commission je n'étais pas
venu donc du coup l'idée c'est de voilà
de se présenter de parler autour d'eux
du futur notre futur olympique
cette compétition ne sera pas aux jeux
olympiques malheur a eu le mérite de
mettre à l'épreuve les muscles des
participants ce week-end la troisième
édition du run and bike de plaisir était
organisée ce samedi matin il a réuni
plus de 600 participants sur cinq
courses des images signées à nicolas
kirilow liszt de la cohésion un esprit
d'équipé une bonne préparation des
ingrédients indispensables pour briller
sur la troisième édition du run and bike
de plaisir ce samedi 7 octobre
l'événement réunit 600 participants
répartis sur cinq courses le 15 km à 2
km puis le coup de vis nommé son avion
ne fait pas grand chose ensemble donc là
c'est sympa ça nous permet de faire
quelque chose ensemble ça ça change
pour moi c'est la première fois je
participe
course comme ça donc le but c'est
d'arriver de faire le débat elle arrive
le tracé a été dessiné en pleine nature
entre le parc du château de plaisir le
bois de la crâne un circuit tout terrain
vous avez effectivement c'est assez
vallonné le départ est assez pentue on
va dire et plus après vous avez
différentes petites difficultés dans la
forêt sur le 15 km la course a été
remportée par olivier derquenne et yann
fret en 51 minutes et 40 secondes avec
près de 38 secondes d'avancé sur les
deuxièmes du classement
c'est pas les champions du monde mais
une petite victoire c'est toujours bon à
prendre ses jambes à ça fait chaud au
coeur c'est le plaisir
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour un
quatrième run and bike à plaisir selon
les organisateurs le lieu du parcours
pour échanger lors de la prochaine
édition
en rugby nouvelle défaite pour le club
de montigny le bretonneux dans le
championnat de promotion honneur les
signé mon teint se sont inclinés contre
garches 11 à 8 à la maison lors de la 2e
journée du championnat et flirte avec la
zone de relégation le résumé du match
par nicolas landry deuxième match
deuxième défaite de la saison pour
montigny le bretonneux les inimités 1 se
sont inclinés de justesse 8 à 11 à la
maison face à garches une partie
équilibrée entre les deux équipes
ça s'est joué sur des petits détails et
voilà le groupe pour l'instant pas été
capables de gagner par rapport à ces
détails mais voilà on reste positif et
puis on va travailler pour faire la
différence pourtant lésigny montants ont
bien entamé la rencontre après avoir
ouvert le score sur une pénalité
montigny le bretonneux inscrire le
premier essai du match le demi de mêlée
ouvre le deuxième centre prend
l'intervalle raffûte et aplatit derrière
la vie
8 à 0 pour les verts mes gars je réagis
les rouge et blanc s'installe dans les
22 mètres de montigny plusieurs maul
lésigny montain multiplient les fautes
et finissent par plier gars je reviens à
trois longueurs juste avant la mi temps
lors de la seconde période la tension
monte d'un cran
larbitre distribuer plusieurs cartons
suite à des fautes répétées les gars
choix reviennent au score et passe
devant grâce à deux pénalités montigny
le bretonneux aurait pu l'emporter mais
laissait finalement refusé par l'arbitré
suite à un contact entre deux joueurs
ini montrent un pas devant pendant qu'on
a encore des matches à domicile on va
chez les joueurs et les équipes têtes en
1re série avec nous l'année dernière
donc on compte aller gagner à
l'extérieur on compte gagner nos matchs
à domicile mais maintenant on va pas
lâcher trop de questions montigny le
bretonneux se retrouve à la 8e place aux
portes de la zone rouge
prochain match dimanche face au deuxième
du classement sur le terrain de saint
maur on continue par un résultat de
rugby le sky joue également ce week-end
son deuxième match de la saison dans le
championnat honneur les saint quentinois
se sont inclinés à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de cergy pontoise sur le score
de 31 à 24
une défaite qui relègue sky rugby à la
7e place du classement avec 5 points et
un bilan d'une victoire et une défaite
handball on avait également la tête des
mauvais jours chez les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux lésigny montaigne
se sont inclinés à l'extérieur sur le
terrain de palaiseau lors de la 3e
journée du championnat de nationale 2 le
score 31 à 20 une défaite qui condamne
montigny le bretonneux à la dernière
place du classement ce début de
championnat
un mot de basket trappe jouer ce
week-end le gros derby de sa poule en
nationale 3 contre marly le roi sur son
parquet et les trappistes n'ont pas été
en réussite puisqu'il s'incline de deux
points contre leurs voisins yvelinois 73
à 71 premier avant la rencontre les
trappistes redescendre la troisième
place à un petit point du fauteuil de
leader
ce week-end on joue également le 5e tour
de la coupe de france de football
béninois zee club de deuxième division
de district s'est incliné 2-1 sur sa
pelouse contre aubervilliers l'équipe
qui évolue trois divisions au-dessus les
yvelinois ont réussi à tenir le match
nul jusqu'à la 80e minute
dans le second match qui nous
intéressait ce week-end versa et vu son
match arrêté un jour de marly la ville a
été victime d'un malaise cardiaque
pendant la rencontre
le match devrait être rejoué le week-end
prochain on continue à parler de
football coup de projecteur aujourd'hui
l'équipe seniors de l'étoile sportive de
trappes qui évolue en r4 pour nous
parler des ambitions du club new rose
second sur ce plateau le capitaine
hamidou sissoko bonsoir alors nous
sommes un peu plus d'un mois du coup du
début de la saison comment sentez vous
l'équipe va bien même si on fait un
début de saison assez moyen avec 2
victoires et 2 défaites
mais bon il ya
il ya du positif on sent qu'il ya des
choses en positif pour la suite du
championnat
il ya l'équipe a été vachement modifier
cet été avec beaucoup de départs de
joueurs importants mais bon là on en
train de reconstruire et des joueurs du
club et on n'y a pas d'inquiétude à
avoir pour la suite alors vous basez
plutôt sur les joueurs du club du moins
pour cette nouvelle saison et que des
renforts venus de l'extérieur
non non c'est principalement des joueurs
qui ont été formés au club qui viennent
des catégories inférieures qui ont
l'esprit du club et qui vont pouvoir
poursuivre la continuité avec ce coup
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer vous
disiez 2 victoires 2 défaites
qu'est ce qu'il faut améliorer dans
cette équipe l'efficacité déjà on n'a
pas marqué beaucoup de buts même si on a
une assez bonne défense mais pouvoir
gagner il faut marquer évidemment et du
coup voilà on est encore en début de
saison la saison va être très très
longues
donc c'est pour ça que je m'inquiète pas
vrai ce niveau là on va parler du
dernier match de championnat contre
lognes c'est le match vraiment qu'il ne
fallait pas manquer en ce début de
saison
pour vous mettre dans une nouvelle
dynamique je pense qu'il ya tous les
mois je ne sont pas loupés
après si on avait gagné c'est clair que
ça aurait été beaucoup mieux pour la
confiance
voilà maintenant
on a perdu on va pas s'arrêter là dessus
il faut passer à autre chose et
justement corriger ce qui n'a pas été
bon pour la suite vous remarquez peu
mais vous avez en contrepartie une très
bonne défense vous encaissez très peu de
buts c'est votre force aussi l'une de
nos forces
bien sûr la dernière on a terminé
meilleure défense on va s'appuyer là
dessus pour cette saison aussi comme je
disais corrigé maintenant s'améliorer au
niveau de l'efficacité trouver un
équilibre et pouvoir enchaîner les
bonnes performances
les bons résultats au niveau de la
mentalité de l'effectif est ce que tout
le monde adhère au discours de arnaud
abhisit le coach actuel de l'équipe
est ce que vous sentez les autres
joueurs concentrés aux entraînements est
prêt à appliquer vraiment les consignes
du coach
bien sûr bien sûr cerneaux ça fait
longtemps qu'il est au club
il a connu pratiquement tous les joueurs
qu'il a actuellement
sous son commandement donc voilà c'est
quelqu'un de très posé qui ce qui fait
donc forcément c'est plus facile pour
nous les joueurs et pour lui aussi vie
qui connaît les joueurs depuis vraiment
tout petit donc il a pu voir leur
progression et c'est comment les
utiliser chacun à leur poste au niveau
des matchs et c'est important d'avoir un
esprit familial dans un club local
ça aide ça va être sûr c'est important
c'est ça facilite beaucoup de choses on
dit ça on n'a pas besoin de parler pour
se comprendre
donc voilà ça ça facile beaucoup les
choses alors vous êtes actuellement à 5e
du classement
c'est une classe qui vous convient ou
viser plus haut ben si on élit temps
nous avait dit et dans une précédente
émission vous visiez le top 3 bien sûr
qu'à la fin de saison c'est on va pas se
cacher c'est en joue pour la montée
surtout avec la réforme des des
championnats faudra en profiter cette
saison voilà donc la dernière la loupe
et de très très peu on espère que cette
année ça sera la bonne enfin on voit le
classement en ce moment même est ce que
vous êtes à votre place finalement ça on
voit sarcelles meaux lognes qui vous a
battu le week-end précédent ce sera ce
seront les équipes favorites pour la
montée des flots on est on est à notre
place voilà c'est mérité on
n'a pas volé on n'hérite pas mieux de
victoires des défaites
on a notre place après voilà il ya des
très bonnes équipes dans le championnat
aussi ça va être un championnat serré
vous faites partie des favoris on va pas
se mettre dans la peau d'un favori mais
on va jouer crânement notre chance et
c'est une obligation pour au club de
monter cette saison on va pas se mettre
de pression inutile en disant que c'est
une obligation mais un objectif pour
parler d'obligations mes objectifs on
espère vous revoir sur ce plateau dans
quelques mois pour des annonces est
justement une place dans le train dans
les trois premiers voire rien coûté
merci à vous hamidou sissoko mercier
vous êtes passé sur ce plateau est très
bonne fin de saison mais aussi un très
bon déroulement de saison dû venir à
trappes
merci beaucoup un mot de baseball à
présent le nouveau terrain du stade jean
maréchal 2 montigné bretonne utilisé
principalement par l'équipe locale des
cougars a officié officiellement été
inauguré ce dimanche matin après
plusieurs semaines de rénovation et un
retard d'un mois dans les travaux pour
l'occasion un match amical était
organisé entre les sportifs du club les
joueurs ont pu fouler cette nouvelle
pelouse entièrement refaite on écouta ni
boutons la présidente des cougars c'est
un terrain de nouvelle génération
donc c'est vrai qu'il sera plus plus
facile pour les joueurs ça leur donnera
moins mal au genou
puisque le dernier terra était en fin de
vie il était relativement dur les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux
testeront leur nouveau stade en
compétition mois de mars prochain pour
leur premier match de la saison de
division 1
la saison de baseball se déroulent du
mois de mars au mois de septembre
direction à présent les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
sixième édition du golfe expérience
anciennement appelée golf festival était
organisée ce samedi dans la structure
plus de 600 personnes ont fait le
déplacement pour apprendre gratuitement
le golfe et surtout découvrir en avant
première le village ambulant de la ryder
cup 2018 qui s'exportera dans toutes les
villes du territoire
reportage de nicolas qui l'habitent
ce samedi 7 octobre
yasmine neuf ans à travailler son swing
sous l'oeil de son père au golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
elle fait partie des six ans novice qui
ont participé à cette sixième édition
dans la golf l'expérience un événement
gratuit encadrés par des experts puis
c'était plutôt rigolo les facile qu'il a
présentée via des balles réussies dévale
où j'ai pas réussi il s'agit d'un secret
très très bien c'est très bien et je
pense qu'il faut il pouvoir faire ce
genre de l'expérience encore souvent la
renouveler puis les inciter à leur
donner envie leur donner envie de taper
dans la balle pour aider les novices les
joueurs confirmés à progresser des
capteurs ont été installés sur les
différents ateliers
objectif les aider à améliorer le jeu
long et le jeu qu avec ça on va pouvoir
aider le joueur
à travailler les bons points aller
travailler dans le bon sens pas aller
dans un chemin qui va pas être le bon
pour le voir corriger plus facilement
les défauts du joueur avec des données
mathématiques tous les coûts doit être
bon et précis et important de bien se
connaître soi même
tous les paramètres qui influent sur la
performance en parallèle des activités
sportives les golfeurs en herbe ont pu
découvrir en avant première un village
ambulant dédié la ryder cup 2018 qui se
déroulera au golf national
le but c'est de parler et leur expliquer
ce qu'est la ryder cup justement donc on
a toutes une tente de promotion où on
parle justement de la ryder cup on
allait de documentation à remettre aux
visiteurs on a une tante qui détient la
réalité virtuelle
enfin c'est une visite virtuelle du golf
national de saint-quentin jamais venu
sur ce site exceptionnel
on leur propose du coup d'une manière
très immersive il est très émotionnel de
découvrir ce site à partir de novembre
ce village ambulant va s'exporter à
l'extérieur des frontières du golf
national 20 événements sont déjà
programmés sur 11 communes de 50 ans et
demi jusqu'à l'organisation de la ryder
cup en septembre 2018
si vous voulez assister la ryder cup
2018 la compétition est programmé comme
vous pouvez le voir sur cette
infographie du 28 au 30 septembre 2008
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
si vous êtes intéressé et reste encore
quelques places ryder cup
encore et toujours dans ce set 8 sports
mercredi dernier sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines l'union
sportive du sport scolaire organise une
journée spéciale pour promouvoir cet
événement et le golf auprès des jeunes
700 élèves âgés de 11 à 14 ans plus
s'entraîner et petit à petit les attirer
des palais le plus loin possible sur les
practice toute la journée on l'écouté
alexandra sa madness de lui et ce n'est
16,78 elle revient sur l'objectif de cet
événement c'est vrai que donc l'activité
golfique n'est pas forcément l'activité
populaire l'objectif nous l unss et de
la ronde de plus en plus populaire
l'objectif primordial c'est de se dire
bas que on aimerait maintenant dans les
yvelines au niveau du nss et pourquoi
pas en eps bien que les élèves passent
du golfe comme ils font de l'ultimate
bien du rugby du football
ça serait l'idée on passe maintenant
notre deuxième entretien dans ce set 8
sports et le conseil
l'automobile le gazelle elle mènera lit
une compétition inspiré du rallye des
gazelles est programmée du 4 au 11
novembre dans les dunes marocaines dans
les yvelines un couple aurait un couple
originaire de vélizy-villacoublay a
décidé de tenter l'expérience en duo
nous les recevons sur ce plateau à ma
droite pascal burq qui sera le
navigateur de l'équipe et fabienne
lalande burgaud à ma gauche qui sera la
pilote
on peut le dire bonsoir alors pourquoi
avez vous décidé de vous lancer dans
l'aventuré fabienne a participé déjà
quatre fois au rallye aïcha des gazelles
donc de 2009 à 2012 et je les accompagne
et de l'extérieur dans cette aventure et
l'organisateur du rallye aïcha des
gazelles a lancé le gaz l and men rallye
donc la première addition au mois de
novembre qui est la version mixte en
fait du rallye des gazelles donc et ça
donne envie de pouvoir partager cette
aventure donc avec ma femme sur cette
épreuve
donc vous avez vraiment envie de
participer ça faisait du pouce la
première édition du rallye gas and men
est ce que vous
vous avez poussé justement pour qu'on
organise ce type de rallye pour les
hommes donc je connais le rallye aïcha
des gazelles depuis sa création
pratiquement donc j'admire ce que font
les gazelles dans d'australie et c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une certaine demande
à la fois de domme et aussi de gazelle
qui faisaient leurs alliés qui avaient
envie d'emmener leurs conjoints
sur cette exposition une épreuve de ce
type donc chose faite à partir du mois
de novembre de cette année fabienne vous
n'avez pas hésité une seule seconde à
partir avec pascal ça nous a pris 45
secondes 40/100 bras mois au moins mais
c'était vraiment un
c'est une aventure qui est tellement
belle enfin pour soi pour les autres on
apprend beaucoup de choses sur soi même
au niveau du rallye et et pascal il
avait participé à cette aventure mais de
l'extérieur et là on avait vraiment la
possibilité de qui connaissent de
l'intérieur
on n'a pas licite et j'ai pas hésité il
fallait il fallait qu'on le fasse tous
les deux donc il fallait forcément de
l'argent pour partir est ce que le
budget est bouclé pascal le budget n'est
pas bouclé et paris
non mais là quelques semaines de
l'épreuve voilà la passion prend le
dessus
voilà on
quelques euros de côté pour pouvoir
permettre de partir donc on a encore
trois petites semaines même pas devant
nous si on parle de 31 octobre la route
le 31 octobre pour rejoindre le maroc et
si toutefois on arrivait à trouver bas
ce sera tant mieux sinon on a décidé de
partir de toute manière on partait quoi
qu'il arrive
voilà et au niveau du financement ça
coûte combien
alors participer à ce type de rallye il
faut compter 26 millions 26 mille euros
pour le gazole en mer pour une épreuve
de six jours six jours donc ça
les vingt-six mille euros comprennent
dans l'inscription on est pris en charge
totalement aussi bien le carburant que
l'hébergement la nourriture
bon après c'est très sécurisé si on en
est suivi par satellite
donc même en france on peut suivre
l'équipage sur le site du gazel enmène
pour l'organisation générale un indigent
première fois les deux sens aussi tout
le laisse coup enfin c'est 8 et vous
êtes entraîné comment du coup pour cette
édition alors en cette première édition
nous avons fait des
des entraînements avec avec un nos
partenaires à la ferté gaucher et puis
tu es parti au mois de novembre au maroc
bat pour vous êtes allé repérable pelé
dans votre peau repérer ces on absence
est pas un c'est un parcours qui est
secret on a un secteur géographique à la
limite et ça s'arrête là donc on est
parti non surtout pour apprendre
magré france - coupe apprendre à
communiquer dans la voiture donc choses
pas forcément aisé dans ce type de
situation là c'était ma prochaine
question c'est simple de partir en duo
surtout en couple non non je pense que
déjà deux personnes qui semblent se
connaître dans la vie de tous les jours
des à 1000 mètres de la famille non je
dirais un couple il ya le côté affectif
qui est là et quand il ya des décisions
à prendre et plus la fatigue plus les
incertitudes
on va voir on va gérer parce que le leur
le rallye je rappelle quand même que
c'est entre 13 et 15 heures de conduite
par jour
est on est on est seul au monde donc il
ya une promiscuité qu'on n'a peut-être
pas dans la vie de tous les jours et
voilà donc c'est un avantage sur vous de
partir avec son conjoint
je vous cache pas que j'en sais rien on
vous dira sans retour mais c'est pas je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
pas qui est pas facile parce qu'il faut
il faut vraiment ce qui est dans la
voiture est dans la voiture et que ça
n'impacte pas la vie en dehors du rallye
parce que des moments entendu je pense
qu'il va y en avoir
l'essentiel c'est de ne pas avoir des
cracks et en même temps faut craquer
l'un après l'autre mais surtout pas en
même temps les skis permet à à l'aube un
de dd celui qui craqua à remonter la
pente quoi vous y allez pascal pour
participer ou pour remporter la
compétition
alors je dirai que j'y vais déjà pour
participer parce que je sais que la
performance viendra tout seul si on va
la chercher enfin sur de ce type
d'épreuve
je connais bien il ya tellement
d'éléments de facteurs extérieurs qui
peuvent intervenir sur la météo
l'environnement qu'on va rencontrer les
prises de décisions la fatigue le stress
fait plein de choses qui peuvent
intervenir c'est pas simplement d'aller
de l'avant comme ça la performance
viendra si on garde la tête froide si on
fait pas trop d'erreurs en termes de
stratégie de navigation puisqu'on n'a
pas de gps et un
on est à travers tous les reliefs juste
avec des cartes d'état major en noir et
blanc des points gps on trace pas de cap
il faut qu'on parcourt la plus courte
distance en pointant le maximum de
points de contrôles de passage donc
c'est de la stratégie
donc il ya un facteur chance peut-être
qu'il pût intervenant aussi merci à tous
les deux passés sur ce plateau ou
souhaite bonne chance pour cette
compétition et on vous souhaite de
terminer le plus haut possible merci à
tous les deux nous allons prendre le
large dans ce set 8 sport pour parler de
voile après avoir participé au vendée
globe
l'année dernière le skipper versets et
tanguy de lamotte va repartir pour la
transat jacques vabre en duo avec
samantha davies une course
transatlantique entre le havre et
salvador 5 novembre prochain le jour du
départ les deux navigateurs pourront
compter sur un soutien de poids vous le
voyez à l'écran
l'astronaute français thomas pesquet
amis de tanguy la mode sera présent à
leurs côtés été choisi pour être le
parrain du bateau imoca initiative coeur
pour cette édition
et puis d'ailleurs le tester en mer avec
le skipper versailles et on écoute
thomas pesquet il ya plein de parallèles
entre laventure l'exploration spatiale
ce qu'on fait nous dans l'espace ce que
fait tanguer est ce que font les
navigateurs en haute mer eh bien on est
isolé on part tout seul on se confronte
à un milieu extrême on utilise la
technologie il faut se préparer comme
des sportifs mais pas de haut niveau
mais quand même des sportifs donc donc à
tout ça on en parle on en discute on
échange on s'est rapprochés sur le
projet du vendée globe et où pendant moi
j'étais dans la station spatiale est un
guide où il affrontait la mère sur son
bateau on était un peu en parallèle
comme ça c'était une belle aventure
et voilà on a ici de la continue
aujourd'hui avec ce bateau là et en plus
tout ça pour une bonne cause
ce sera la dernière course de tanguy de
lamotte avant une longue pause pour
raisons familiales tentera de viser le
top 5 de la transat jacques vabre pour
cette édition on passe maintenant notre
rubrique agenda
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer si vous
êtes un passionné à deux footballs
variétés club de france saura ce
mercredi soit à 19 heures au stade léo
lagrange de poissy sur la pelouse le
public pourra voir en action sonny
anderson laurent blanc didier deschamps
alain giresse et bixente lizarazu
l'ensemble des recettes de ce match
caritatif sera reversée au profit de
l'association plus de vie présidée par
l'ancienne première dame bernadette
chirac en football maurepas leader du
championnat de première division de
district reçoit le pec au stade du bout
des clos ce dimanche à 15h la mort pas
bien seront favoris de cette rencontre
ils sont pour l'instant premier avec un
bilan de 3 victoires et 1 nul et surtout
ils ont la meilleure attaque du
championnat avec 11 buts inscrits de son
côté le pecq pointe à la 8e place et n'a
encaissé qu'un seul but une opposition
de style qui s'annonce passionnante
des images insolites à présent pour
refermer ce magazine une section de
quidditch baptisé les aigles s and p's
vient de voir le jour aux
clayes-sous-bois une première dans le
département des yvelines ce sport de
balle a été inventé dans la saga harry
potter par l'auteure jk rowling est
adaptée dans la réalité par des fans
pour attirer un maximum de joueurs à un
entraînement est ouvert aux petits et
aux grands la semaine dernière au parc
jean carillon on écoute le président du
club gilles guillou en fait on n'est pas
des sorciers c'est en fait il lui dit je
me le dis parce qu'on n'a pas le on est
pas on n'est pas magicien donc on veut
le pape dont concours avec des balais
mais le but c'est ouais c'est de
permettre aux enfants qui connaissent
l'univers d'harry potter ou même les
grands comme moi qu'ils puissent
s'amuser courir et puis pouvoir
participer à des compétitions le club
des aides laisse hunt participera à la
coupe de france de quidditch les 18 et
19 novembre prochains
avant cet entraînement ouvert au public
la structure comptait à cette inscrit
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]